foreign
there are many players that made an
impact in the tekking community all
throughout the years
players that just made the game much
better and more interesting in terms of
their skills and competitiveness in the
tournament scene
most of them still compete today
professionally but sadly some just
stopped playing players whom the
community looked up to but became
inactive all of a sudden
[Applause]
here are some players that we miss and
needs to go back in Tekken 8.
[Music]
[__]
flip it
up
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
shut up
[Music]
thank you
okay I didn't I didn't know that
in that situation but to be honest with
the lighthouse we're really just Ole
Miss and Jabs he hasn't been going low
much
[Music]
oh [__]
s like frisbees here we go
[Music]
give it up
good
night
Triple H with the first combo whoa good
damage
[Music]
finds the combo
thank you
[Music]
hey Google
is Jimmy
I don't remember oh man happy birthday
all right
that was beautiful again
[Music]
but not enough cash good block
[Applause]
[Music]
two fish
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
sit around
that wasn't electric
and look at that wow
oh very nice
that's the thing is you glitch might die
yeah okay one little mistake look at
this time again
[Music]
is it gonna happen we're going to a
final
s
[Music]
did we miss someone just comment below
and make sure to like And subscribe for
more Tekken content
[Music]
foreign